y
los chilenos castigaron a la clase
política tradicionales sobre todo a la
centroderecha en las elecciones para
conformar la asamblea que redactará la
nueva constitución del país tras un fin
de semana electoral en los
independientes obtuvieron una
representación inédita con 48 puestos de
los 155 miembros tenemos reportes desde
santiago
otra intensa ronda de bombardeos en el
octavo día del conflicto entre israel y
las milicias palestinas en gaza el
ejército israelí aseguró haber destruido
túneles del grupo islamista hamás
mientras tanto la comunidad
internacional no logra unificar
posiciones para mediar un conflicto que
está teniendo un alto costo para la
población civil en la franja
y el gobierno colombiano y el comité del
paro promotor de las protestas
nacionales aún no llegan a un acuerdo el
comité pide retirar al ejército y a la
policía antidisturbios del control en
las marchas por el uso excesivo de la
fuerza el diálogo seguirá este lunes y
ya se anunció una nueva gran
movilización para el próximo 19 de mayo
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí comienzan las noticias de
france 24 iniciamos el informativo con
noticias de chile ya se conocen los
resultados del super fin de semana
electoral en el que la ciudadanía votó a
los 255 constituyentes para reescribir
la constitución además de cargos
regionales con cerca del 100 por ciento
de los votos escrutados en la mayoría de
los escaños los obtuvieron los
independientes con 48 puestos las dos
grandes listas de la oposición de
izquierda se sumaron 52 27 de apruebo
dignidad y 25 de lista del pueblo y la
coalición gobernante de centro-derecha
vamos desde el presidente sebastián
piñera obtuvo sólo una quinta parte de
representación con 38 sillas para tomar
decisiones se necesitarán dos tercios de
la asamblea por lo que el gobierno
tendrá problemas para impulsar o
bloquear cambios radicales a menos que
logre alianzas 17 puestos quedaron
reservados para los pueblos originarios
vamos a ir hacia santiago de chile- con
nuestra corresponsable de patricia luna
patricia buenos días para usted y
comienzo preguntándole con estos
resultados cuéntenos cómo se perfila el
futuro de esta constituyente histórica
para los chilenos la ciudadanía eligió a
los independientes y cambió el rumbo
político con un claro rechazo a los
partidos tradicionales
buenos dias angela desde lo que es sin
duda un nuevo chile el propio presidente
del gobierno sebastián piñera reconocía
anoche la desconexión de los partidos
políticos con la ciudadanía y como estos
resultados indican que es necesario que
estos partidos políticos realicen una
profunda reflexión esto es muy
importante porque el presidente es poco
dado a la autocrítica y anoche sin duda
lo hizo
vemos una composición de la convención
constituyente marcada por las fuerzas de
centroizquierda y donde también la lista
de independientes que constituye la
lista del pueblo una una lista que
tiende hacia él
hacia la izquierda bastante más extrema
está presente con 24 escaños esto
obligará a las distintas fuerzas de la
convención constituyente a lograr
acuerdos veremos una convención
constituyente en la que es difícil
alcanzar acuerdo pues patricia
muchísimas gracias por este adelanto y
en minutos el regreso con ustedes con
nuestros televidentes para un análisis
de lo que fueron estas elecciones y de
combo cambiará el rumbo de chile
cambiamos de tema por el momento es el
octavo día de combates en la franja de
gaza sin señales de una tregua por
segundo día consecutivo israel lanzó
intensos bombardeos desde la madrugada
que según el ejército alcanzaron los
objetivos de hamas 54 aviones cazas
israelíes destruyeron 15 kilómetros de
túneles del grupo islamista y 9
viviendas de sus comandantes las
milicias palestinas respondieron con
nuevos lanzamientos de cohetes a
comunidades israelíes cercanas al menos
198 palestinos han muerto desde el nuevo
estallido del conflicto y más de 1200
resultaron heridos también fallecieron
10 israelíes el domingo el consejo de
seguridad de la onu pidió el fin de la
violencia pero fracasó en su intento de
enviar un mensaje común y conjunto dado
el apoyo de eeuu a la postura israelí
para ampliar la información nos
comunicamos con nuestra corresponsal
entre la viven mayas y minobis vaya buen
día para ustedes
los tímidos intentos de mediación de
actores internacionales no han dado
resultados repasemos quienes han
intentado mediar en la crisis y qué
respuestas han encontrado
hola buenas exactamente como dices son
muy tímidos los intentos por alcanzar
una tregua o eso parece el secretario
general de la onu me ha pedido ya en
reiteradas ocasiones el cese de las
hostilidades que llama espantosas y en
tres ocasiones eeuu ha bloqueado esa
petición por un lado está la onu que
está exigiendo el cese hostilidades y
por otro lado está eeuu que por un lado
dice que entiende el derecho legítimo de
israel a defenderse y por otro lado está
pidiendo que esto no vaya más sin
embargo no hay una declaración en firme
desde el punto de vista de eeuu y es
esto lo que más cuenta aquí en israel
también los esfuerzos por alcanzar una
tregua por parte de qatar y de egipto
están cayendo en saco roto lo que parece
que está pasando es que israel tiene
unos objetivos militares muy claros a
seguir y no parece que quiera detenerlos
hasta que no los logre desde otro punto
de vista
hamas y la jihad islámica también tienen
algunos objetivos así dicen analistas
israelíes
todavía tienen mucho arsenal y que tal
vez pretendan usarlo
vaya gracias a usted y el barrio de
sheikh jarrah en jerusalén este juega un
papel clave en el actual conflicto entre
israel y los territorios palestinos la
justicia israelí respaldo en un fallo
inicial unos asentamientos en esta zona
abriendo la puerta al posible desahucio
de comunidades palestinas fue una
decisión que avivó las manifestaciones
contra israel antes de la actual
escalada de violencia en ese contexto
las redes sociales han servido para
exponer al mundo la situación del barrio
el informe desde juan pupiales
un simple barrio convertido en epicentro
de un conflicto de dimensiones
internacionales
sheikh jarrah es un distrito palestino
en la ocupada jerusalén este una zona
que a su vez tiene una importancia
religiosa para los judios albergando la
tumba de simón primero el justo un
prominente sacerdote situado al norte de
la ciudad vieja de jerusalén este punto
ya ha empezado a recibir nuevos
asentamientos israelíes frente a una
comunidad palestina que teme ser
desahuciada en octubre una primera
sentencia de la justicia israelí falló
en favor de los judios que reclaman que
esta tierra es suya desde antes de 1948
y para denunciar al mundo ese temor a
perder sus hogares muchos han optado por
las redes sociales
la campaña de salvar a sheikh jarrah
comenzó con los residentes y es una
campaña clara y directa contra la
política de desahucios por parte de las
autoridades de ocupación de israel en 6
guerra y también en jerusalén y en toda
la palestina histórica
es precisamente a través de las redes
que se divulgan con transmisiones en
vivo los enfrentamientos que transcurren
con las fuerzas de seguridad en la
actual escalada de violencia les
mostramos lo que está ocurriendo a quién
se guiará específicamente en jerusalén y
en palestina en general
intentamos grabar las escenas que tienen
lugar cada día tales como las
violaciones de nuestros derechos humanos
las comunidades palestinas apelaron ante
la corte suprema de israel el fallo en
favor de los judíos la semana pasada
este tribunal aplazó para comienzos de
junio una audiencia sobre esos
desahucios de las familias palestinas la
sentencia al final de este caso amenaza
con ser un punto de giro en medio de un
contexto ya con muchas atenciones
y en colombia del gobierno y el comité
del paro promotor de las protestas
nacionales que comenzaron el pasado 28
de abril no llegaron a un acuerdo en la
reunión que sostuvieron este domingo el
comité presentó un documento en el que
exige entre otros puntos retirar al
ejército y al es madre de la policía
para controlar las protestas y que el ex
ministro de defensa presente disculpas
públicas por el uso excesivo de la
fuerza durante las marchas mientras
tanto hay nueva convocatoria a
manifestaciones el miércoles 19 de mayo
en rechazo a la brutalidad policial y
las políticas del gobierno del
presidente iván duque han presentado un
documento que tiene dos partes
fundamentales la primera una que se
refiere a las garantías para el
ejercicio de la protesta y la segunda
garantías para las mesas de negociación
lo primero en lo que hay claridad es que
la mesa de negociación aún no se instala
debido a que con este documento que ha
sido presentado por parte del comité
nacional del paro como lo ha dicho el
vocero del comité debe ser analizado por
el gobierno nacional
así llegamos al final del informativo
pero regresamos en minutos con ustedes
para más noticias y para el análisis de
la situación en chile después de los
comicios para la constituyente siga con
nosotros
[Música]